mouth-watering smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
that's away
butts away
now this is incredible there's the
shoulder yeah and look there's the
shoulder blade if you go through here
there's a knuckle there that's
connecting the top and that's why
it's called a butt
the slower you cook it the more juicy it
is and is great for big parties because
you just come along and get your fork
and shred it a delicious smoky
mayonnaise and you're away onions into
half and half again okay i'm gonna leave
the roots on okay because i want this to
sit underneath the pore
it gives it a chance to cook evenly it
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now i'll peel the garlic
okay i'd like you
to crush the garlic we're gonna make a
really nice little paste
okay
go on maggie
come on come on come on
nice good girl one more
crush
come on maggie i'm coming
sorry about that
little
cup there now this
is a beauty
paprika smoked paprika i love it so
three nice tablespoons in
okay
two
large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt please and pepper could go
[Laughter]
so gonna form a nice paste now
olive oil in
mix that some time in there so we got
sort of fragrant rub
time stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now
this is where you've got to be really
quick okay
and sort of rub that mash sergeant in
almost exactly that
smells amazing honestly
just drizzle a little touch of olive oil
on top of that for me
i keep the pork nice and moist
lovely
like some of the best party dishes the
marinading the pork shoulder can be done
days in advance so if i was doing this
for a sunday and start marinating
thursday friday so it gets even tastier
right quite easy as well to make it's
very easy five and a half to six hours
in the oven
at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts meg
and i are going to pimp some shot-bought
mayonnaise
i don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you can just
twist
yeah there's so many things so many
certain things you can do with it right
salt
pepper
and
little touch of honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and i've got a little bit of
you know this chipotle smoked chipotle
paste i love that once you've made this
dressing
you know it can sit in the fridge
great for open sandwiches yeah you can
use it for any sandwiches really any
sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
i've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
so
that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites
first deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finely dice sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and grate some nutty grilled cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling of grated
greer
these simple cheesy crushed potatoes are
equally delicious served hot or cold
now i want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
i'm gonna make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli
okay the bit everybody wants
once they're off i'm gonna slice the
broccoli
okay mm-hmm never had raw broccoli
before it's always been cooked really
when you dress this with the dressing
it's incredible
now
a little seasoning early on
yeah okay now for the dressing
fresh yogurt in a teaspoon of sugar
please daddy
little smell
cider vinegar mmm there you go
finely chop shallot
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
i love them that gives that nice sort of
chewy texture all right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please
thank you
and stop and then mix that up with me
good girl
a little taste
so good and it's the kind of salad that
doesn't wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the broccoli
is raw
raw broccoli salad
chipotle now let me be the poor cow with
this look at this megan honestly
that
is amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now
that goes to the table like that
delicious
just before we go to the table mega just
a little bit honestly meg don't tell mom
thank you honestly
do i do it i'm gonna do it
man it's incredible so good you promised
me you don't give the recipe to your
boyfriend let's go
come on
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
and quick simple sides of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw
deliciously yummy dishes that will have
your family friends and work buddies
coming back for more right how's the
ball this is very good thank you it's
very tasty
nearly blew my head off oh the perfect
side dish for my fantastic fried chicken
jack
hi my gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely no you love pickles
right love pickles um favorite pickle
what is it i like pickled onions we're
going to do pickled celery it's a nice
little snack and great for plum ones
great for salads first thing we need to
pick the celery for me so you see where
the next one's going to be it's in there
yeah okay i'll figure out well i'm
hungry today is this all we're having
for dinner jack come on i wouldn't do
that too you know that there's more
coming now because we're
picking it
we want to sort of make it
look a little bit more attractive so we
go around like that
okay on an angle
so when you pick all the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also gives it a really nice
salty soury flavour yeah okay now splash
of water and then with the sugar nice
okay
so we've got to bring that up to the
bowl and sort of create
almost like a little syrup yeah okay
little teaspoon of peppercorns in
mustard seeds in quite generous on the
mustard seeds that gives a bit of sort
of spice now those you must know
cloves excellent cloves
in
now touch of salt no
okay so from there white wine vinegar
now
in order for all that to actually
pickle
you need to boil it
so by boiling it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together it fuses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
nice nice see i put some house on your
chest
yes it will look boom it's working
already now see
nice
vinegar
right celery's ready yep okay let's walk
to the ball now
turn that off
now
from there
start placing the celery
into that jar so when you pick other
foods can you use that same recipe
exactly that
100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off mm-hmm okay now put them in there so
can we eat this straight away when it's
in here do you know what as soon as it's
cooled down
you can definitely eat that straight
away i can't wait to dig into it at
dinner aren't they delicious yes we'll
leave that to cool down
our pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken on the fried
chicken traditionally it's always gonna
be done with the dark meat the brown
meat so you've got that nice sort of uh
drum
here and this bit
that thigh cooking on the bone as well
keeps it even more moist so first things
first salt pepper
please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinating the
chicken if you can put this buttermilk
over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax
the chicken and puts a really nice sort
of
creamy soury flavour in there so might
stick that in the fridge for us please
and we'll start the dolce de leche
biscuits nice
the argentinians call these shortbreads
alfa jorge and they're the favorite
sweet treat on the streets of buenos
aires
they're light crumbly shortbread
biscuits sandwiched with gloriously
golden caramelly dolce de leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar
and beat until light and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
slice vanilla pots
scrape out the seeds add to the mix
and beat again
[Music]
sift plain flour
corn flour
and baking powder
then fold the mixture together
using floured hands roll into small
balls
flatten into discs and place on a baking
tray
[Music]
chill for 10 minutes until firm to touch
then simply bake for 10 to 12 minutes or
until pale golden
once cooled
sandwich two biscuits together with a
camry dolce de leche sauce
[Music]
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
[Music]
delicious
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken all that's left is to fry
it now we're gonna
roll the chicken out of the buttermilk
into the flour so that's why it gets
nice and crispy and blistery on the
outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yes
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice
and this
is smoked paprika
so that gives it a little bit of sort of
uh
making yeah yeah spice that's right a
little bit of heat and this one my
favorites what's that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please cool i'm gonna get the pan
on now
two centimetres
of oil this is a really good mix for
fish as well
gushons biting
a nice spicy
texture helps fish
so first thing
is we just shake off some of the
buttermilk lay that down yes okay really
important to get them covered completely
okay
in the flour yeah okay
so i love fried chicken do you
now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you off you
go nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yep just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
good
gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through
now very carefully turn them over please
yeah cool
can we have this every day
jack fried chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah now
off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay onto the
paper
sell them
i love
fried chicken i'm telling you i'm pretty
sure i love it morning look here's the
best bit
delicious now
fried chicken
are pickles if you pick up um dolce de
leche cakes we are ready bud
very nice that's good
delicious uncle mummy wow tilly phoebe
rum
divine dolce de leche biscuits my
pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken a soulful street food feast if
there ever was one
and joining the ramsay clan tonight is
tilly's schoolmate phoebe
now first of all we have some very very
exciting pickled celery phoebe and i'll
have a drum please here we go nice
ladies you can lift it up with your
fingers especially on the drums good
because i can't do this
finger licking chicken that's right
phoebe has a chicken
amazing i won't be able to like make
this at all yes you would yes you will
it's so easy to make you see yourself
it's very easy to make right
dad did say we could have it every night
in the week
what i said as a treat
it's chicken so it's healthy right you
always take you always tell me to eat my
chicken well chicken is healthy but not
fried every night okay
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you know what phoebe's favorite show is
what's phoebe's favorite show
yeah tell me
um well sometimes i watch jamie oliver's
15-minute meal
sometimes you watch jamie oliver's
15-minute
meals 15 minutes so
freebie
taxi's here